[Music]
it's so obvious that it's practically
proverbial you can't unboiled
well it turns out you can sort of what
thermal energy does to the eggs
molecules mechanical energy can undo
eggs are mostly made of water and
proteins the proteins start off folded
up into intricate shapes held together
by weak chemical bonds adding heat
disrupts those bonds allowing the
proteins to unfold uncoil unwind and
wiggle freely this process is called
denaturing the newly liberated proteins
bump up against their neighbors and
start to form new bonds with each other
more and more as the heat increases
until finally they're so entangled that
they gel into a solid mass a boiled egg
that entanglement might look permanent
but it's not according to a chemical
idea called the principle of microscopic
reversibility anything that happens like
egg proteins seizing up can
theoretically unhappen if you retrace
your steps but adding more heat will
tangle the proteins further and cooling
them down will only freeze them so
here's the trick spin them around
ridiculously fast I'm not kidding
here's how it works first scientists
dissolve boiled egg whites in water with
a chemical called urea a small molecule
that acts as a lubricant coating the
proteins long strands and making it
easier for them to glide past each other
then they spin that solution in a glass
tube at a breakneck 5,000 rotations per
minute making the solution spread out
into a thin film here's the key part the
solution nearest the wall spins faster
than the solution closer to the middle
that difference in velocity creates
shear stresses that repeatedly stretch
and contract the proteins until
eventually they snap back into their
native shapes and stay there by the time
the centrifuge stops spinning the egg
white is back in its original on
boiled state this technique works with
all sorts of proteins bigger Messier
proteins can be more resistant to being
pulled apart so scientists attach a
plastic bead to one end that adds extra
stress and encourages it to fold up
first this unboiled
in its shell since the solution has to
spread throughout a cylindrical chamber
but the applications go way beyond
uncook in your breakfast
anyhow many pharmaceuticals consist of
proteins that are extremely expensive to
produce partly because they get stuck in
tangled up aggregates just like cooked
egg whites and have to be untangled and
re folded before they can do their jobs
this spinning technique has the
potential to be an easier cheaper and
quicker method than other ways to refold
proteins so it may allow new drugs to be
made available to more people faster and
there's one more thing you need to keep
in mind before trying to uncook all of
your food boiling an egg is actually an
unusual cooking process because even
though it changes the way proteins are
shaped and bound together it doesn't
actually change their chemical identity
most types of cooking are more like the
famous meillard reaction which makes
chemical changes that turn sugars and
proteins into delicious caramel
crunchiness and are a lot harder to undo
so you might be able to unbale your egg
but I'm sorry to say you can't fun fry
it yet
[Music]